[Music]
you
Alex Gorsky CEO of Johnson & Johnson
welcome to the industrialist awawa hey
Rob it's great to be here thank you so
much for coming what I'd like to ask you
first is tell us a little bit about the
business you've got three major product
groups ready medical devices
pharmaceuticals and consumer products
how do you deal with managing the
complexity of these three different
groups and getting them to coordinate or
not yeah well first of all Rob it's
great to be here you know this is where
I started my career in the Army actually
not too far away from here in the 7th
Infantry Division down in Fort Ord
California started my career with
Johnson & Johnson so to come back here
it's always a real honor and I love the
weather but particularly in February but
I think one of the the greatest aspects
of Johnson & Johnson is the diversity of
businesses that we have you know frankly
they were the most important drivers of
our success and performance over the
last hundred and thirty two years is
because of our diverse model and you
know it starts with a belief that we
want to go where the best opportunity is
you know whether it's a pharmaceutical
opportunity with it's a medic medtech
opportunity a consumer opportunity if
it's ultimately going to help patients
or consumers we want to be able to bring
our technology to bear our capabilities
our global footprint and frankly help
people feel better and and by playing
and participating in all those spaces we
can do that too it's been a huge reason
of our financial success you know when
you're in business for over 130 years
there are going to be cycles when some
businesses are up and others are down
we've experienced it across all of our
businesses and in having those different
levers and having that diversity and
then frankly the financial wherewithal
and you know one of the reasons I think
we frankly have had 55 consecutive years
of dividend increases and 34 consecutive
years of operational EPS increases a
triple-a credit rating it's because of
the diversity of our businesses now for
me intellectually it's awesome you know
I can be in one room talking about the
next Carty amino oncology approach I
walk into the next and you're talking
about the next approach and robotic
surgery then I walk into the next room
and it should we use Jennifer Aniston or
Kerry Washington and this particular
advertisement for you know one of our
Neutrogena products and I think that's
true for all of our employees
offers you a diverse array you can work
in Johnson & Johnson and be part of a
startup in a small group you can then
scale it and be running a multi-billion
dollar you know division so really
whether its strategic whether its
financial or frankly with our employees
in mind I think the diversity of our
business is really one of our strongest
traits if you look at the changing
nature of health care in particulars
over the last decade and going forward
what we've learned about the human body
the information about the human body and
how we can actually treat indications
and diseases is one of the big
differences of what were confronting how
is data becoming something that's
changing the nature of how Johnson &
Johnson does business well I've got to
tell you I've been in this business for
almost 30 years now and I can't think of
a more exciting time to be in this
industry because of the explosion that's
taking place in science and technology
and for someone who was in this industry
in the 1990s when frankly they were
criticized for a lot of me too
behavioral modification therapies versus
life-changing life-saving therapies to
be in the industry now we're literally
we're on the cusp of curing things like
HIV like hepatitis C where you can have
a hip procedure like I did a couple of
years ago and walk out and be walking
with a walker or you know around the
recovery floor within a couple of hours
is pretty remarkable and I think a lot
of this new technology that we're seeing
again whether it's science or or med
tech or consumer that's being driven by
this explosion explosion in digital
technology right now so let me give you
a couple of examples I think that you
know just this morning I was talking to
some of the leaders in our Innovation
Center and they were talking about some
of the new approaches where how can we
combine better Diagnostics with some of
our approaches oncology because we know
for example the tumors that likely all
of us have once we've reached out
certain aids or certain we have
anomalous growths taking place and
malignancies why can't we detect those
very early on just the way that we would
for example in a cholesterol test
before they've had a chance to multiply
and become very invasive in the way that
we can enable that of course to
understand that one cell or our immune
system has respond in a certain way we
can only do that through data right by
basically knowing that this particular
number of cells is increased this is
decreasing and having the data analytics
to understand the genome is all
facilitated by Big Data and and so it's
germane there if I look at a place like
our medical device space going forward
robotics today when you think about its
surgeries perform much in the much in a
similar way that you would say the
person driving a car and you're going
through and yes there's a lot of skills
there's a lot of experience and
capabilities think how we could improve
that if we had more real-time data being
provided to that surgeon as he or she
was actually maneuvering their way
through a particular you know type of
procedure and last but not least if on
the consumer side if you want your
products to be at the right place at the
right time if you want to go beyond
product to experience and engage with
those consumers it's all based on
digital and so having those capabilities
more is more important than ever how do
you think about distributing some of the
information moving stuff to the cloud I
mean it's been written about a lot of
the work at Johnson & Johnson has done
and thinking about issues around privacy
as well as hiring the right skill sets
and competencies maybe that are
different from the legacy of what built
the organization to what it was before
to what it needs to be in the future
well really the only reason we can do
all of this is because we have cloud
capabilities and and frankly it gives us
the ability to sift to move to converge
more and more data sets and and when you
think about the amount of information
that we have you know let's just talk
for example in our pharmaceutical
business how do you pull all that
information together that exists about
new targets all the papers that have
been published in a particular area to
really understand a particular field
we've got to be able to have the cloud
to do that in an effective way on the
back end once we have a product that
goes out collecting all those safety
data bases working with the epics the
Cerner's in the world the United
Health's of the world the optimist to
pull all that together to see how
used in world settings literally you
can't do it without the cloud you know
how do we engage with mothers on baby
calm right where we can almost predict
where they are in the stage with their
baby what they can expect how we can
help them you know manage their their
their life you know through of you know
a very challenging time with a newborn
that's all based upon our ability to
pull that data together so yeah more and
more not only are we a healthcare
technology newer company we're a
healthcare technology company
so speaking of which the last three
years we've had a majeski visit us you
know CEO of 23andme and I think when you
were heading up JJ DC you actually you
know we're part of you know led up the
investment in her company what did you
see in what they're doing that you
thought might be a good way to partner
with that organization that could help
you be successful for your customers
well and great entrepreneur and I've had
the privilege of meeting there and as
you said when I was responsible for
directly responsible for Johnson Johnson
Development Corporation we made that
investment and at that time we felt that
there were a couple of major trends that
were reflected or really epitomized by
23andme the first is the power of the
genome and utilizing the power of the
genomes to have a much better
fundamental understanding of underlying
pathology and in disease in biology how
do we bring all that together to get
much more targeted more personalized in
our response that's enabled by the
genome the second was consumerization
you know anymore all the consumer has to
do is get online do a couple of clicks
and they can get a level of information
that was only available to a physician a
PhD or you know somebody who would study
in a particular field for many many
years only ten years ago and so we saw
23andme at that time as being a great
way to learn there's so many of our
investments we really not are not
looking at them from a financial return
point of view but where can we go and
learn how can we have a seat at the
table to be learning about new fields or
emerging that ultimately
we know is going to benefit patients
consumers and Johnson & Johnson so as
you think about partnerships you know
you've got this large organization with
a
of right highly educated people who are
experts in their field then you have to
decide what are you gonna do it
internally and one are you gonna partner
externally how does Johnson & Johnson
filter that understanding of what do you
need to own and what do you need to
partner with well you're right I'm
incredibly lucky I get to work with
about a hundred and thirty four thousand
other associates that are very smart
committed hard-working values-based and
frankly that's they're the people who
make us who we are and we couldn't do it
without them but we also know that we
can't do everything and so what's
interesting if you look across johnson
johnson be it in a pharmaceutical group
a medical device group or a consumer
group about 50% of the time we develop
things discover and develop things
internally and about 50% of the time we
go external and and that's been the case
for the last twenty ten five years and
frankly we're agnostic about the source
of the science we want the best science
and technology and and we know
especially in today's world where
science and it's happening such a
ubiquitous manner around the globe that
if you're not constantly making
connections building relationships with
academic centers with the venture
community with other startups you're
never going to be at the cutting edge of
science and so what we love to do is
spot that early technology externally
know that neutrogena from you know 25 30
years ago BioSense Webster and Elektra
and electrophysiology or you know the
the next compounds such as DARS alexe
and find it early on and then what we
can do is we can bring our scientific
our clinical development or regulatory
our global footprint our commercials or
reimbursement skills to bear and we can
take something it may not even be on the
market and we can then create a billion
dollar platform where you're going to
reach thousands perhaps millions of more
patients and consumers by being part of
Johnson and Johnson so Alex you're
approaching your six year and six year
of being the CEO of the business if you
look forward the time flies when you're
having fun you are the next six to ten
years if you look forward what do you
think are the biggest two or three
challenges that are
it's gonna face J&J in the healthcare
industry more broadly well you know as I
mentioned earlier I think one of the
most exciting things is this explosion
and your science and new technology
we're really moving from treatment to
cure and ultimately I think even how do
we move from cure to prevention and
stopping the in wellness and you know
halting these things before they even
get downstream I think that's the good
news the challenges how are we going to
pay for it and particularly at a time
when frankly demographics are exploding
especially the the population aged 65
and older and you know right now in this
country you know we we're already at
about thirty five forty to forty million
people over the age of 65 that numbers
gonna go to 70 million over the next 30
years when you turn 65 that's when you
consume all your health care in fact
about 5 to 7 times the amount and that's
not only happening here but in China I
think right now they've got about a
hundred and fifty million people over
the age of 65 that number could go to
300 so think about that a population the
size of the United States so on a global
basis we're just gonna see demand for
high-quality value-based health care to
be exploding and I think balancing those
two issues of how do we how do we find a
cure for Alzheimer's that we need
because if we don't find that the impact
that's going to have on humanity will be
just ain't so significant and at the
same time how do we do it in a way where
governments where health care systems
where payers can actually make that
happen
and study that's the big opportunity
that's the big challenge but when when I
couple that with you know again what I'm
seeing in science and technology when I
couple that when when you do bring that
kind of pressure to bear it creates
changes and every time you have a lot of
change it creates new opportunities you
know how do we change our reimbursement
systems how do we you know change from
thinking about paying on a per diem or
product basis to an episode of care and
outcome based approach how do we focus
more on preventing these diseases from
happening in the first place living
better lifestyles so yeah there's a lot
of challenges but I couldn't think of a
more exciting time to be in the industry
it's amazing to think about your
business and not only
complexity and things you accomplished
internally but the size and scope of the
forces outside and how that influences
what you can and can't do big challenges
but also big opportunities in front of
you absolutely you know you look you
you've got to be constantly thinking
about your strategy your resources in
your model and predicating it based on
what's happening in your external
environment and you know as your
customers evolve is they make decisions
in different ways as new capabilities
get introduced such as digitization and
other things if you are internally not
constantly evolving and there's no way
you can be successful Alex thank you so
much for coming to Stanford and visiting
us and coming to the industrialists
dilemma great to be here thank you so
much Cheers
[Music]